(Rires)
J'en étais à un stade où je voulais prendre ça au sérieux.
Je voulais analyser,
comprendre pourquoi cela prenait le dessus dans ma vie,
pourquoi cela me passionnait,
pourquoi les gens réagissaient autant face à ça.
Et j'ai réalisé quelque chose.
Nous vivons tous dans ce monde digital où tout va vite
mais nous désirons quelque chose qui ait du sens.
Je pense que nous avons perdu notre sensibilité
à force de vivre dans des villes disproportionnées,
à cause de tous ces panneaux publicitaires,
de ces parkings gigantesques.
Nous ne nous plaignons même plus de tout ça maintenant.
Alors quand vous découvrez
un panneau stop enveloppé d'un tricot,
cela paraît tellement décalé,
et petit à petit - bizarrement -
cela commence à vous parler,
et c'est ce moment.
C'est ce moment que j'aime,
ce moment que j'ai partager avec les autres.
A cet instant, ma curiosité grandit.
C'est parti des bornes incendie et des panneaux stop,
que pouvais-je faire ensuite ?
Pouvais-je réaliser quelque chose de grand,
de massif, d'insurmontable.
C'est à ce moment que j'ai pensé au bus.
Cela a tout changé.
J'ai toujours eu une petite préférence pour celui-là.
A ce moment, les gens reconnaissaient mon travail
mais il n'y avait pas grand-chose
de massif enveloppé de tricot,
et c'était surement le premier bus de ville emballé dans du tricot.
J'expérimentais,
ou du moins observais, quelque chose d'intéressant.
J'ai peut-être inventé le Yarn Bombing mais il ne m'appartient plus.
Il a atteint un niveau mondial
Des gens font cela partout dans le monde.
Je le sais car j'ai voyagé dans des pays
où je n'étais jamais allée,
et j'ai découvert un panneau de stop enveloppé et ce n'était pas moi !
Alors que je poursuivais mes objectifs artistiques,
c'est une de mes dernières œuvres,
le Yarn bombing se développait.
Le phénomène grandissait.
Cette expérience m'a prouvé le pouvoir caché de cet art,
et m'a montré
que je pouvais avoir un langage commun avec le reste du monde.
Grâce à ce hobby de mamie,
ce hobby dur à assumer,
j'avais des affinités avec des gens
avec qui je n'aurais jamais pensé avoir de lien.
Si je raconte mon histoire aujourd'hui,
c'est aussi pour tenter de vous convaincre
que même les plus modestes recèlent en eux une forte énergie
et des talents cachés qui n'attendent que d'être découverts.
Pensons à nos mains, ces outils connectés à nous,
et ce qu'elles sont capables de faire,
construire des maisons et des meubles,
peindre de grandes fresques murales,
et la plupart du temps nos mains tiennent une manette ou un mobile.
Je fais exactement la même chose.
Mais si vous y pensez,
que se passera-t-il si vous lâchez ces choses ?
Que pourriez-vous faire ? Que pourriez-vous créer de vos mains ?
Beaucoup pensent que je suis experte dans l'art du tricot,
mais en vérité je ne pourrais pas me tricoter un pull.
Mais j'ai fait avec le tricot quelque chose d'intéressant
qui n'avait jamais fait.
Je n'étais pas supposée non plus être une artiste
dans le sens où je n'ai pas eu de formation dans ce domaine.
Je suis diplômée en math en fait.
Mon destin n'était pas écrit dans les cartes,
mais je n'ai pas réussi par hasard.
Quand j'ai commencé, je me suis accrochée,
je me suis battue et je suis fière de dire que je vis de mon art aujourd'hui.
Si on se projette dans le futur,
le vôtre non plus ne sera peut-être pas linéaire.
Un jour, vous pourriez aussi en avoir assez et décider
de tricoter une poignée de porte qui changera le cours de votre vie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)